francis do you enjoy social media of
course i love spending my days being
called a fat bigot by strangers
and do you think the woke buyers on
social media is getting ridiculous
yeah what happened to pilate was a
travesty for freedom of speech online
what if i told you there was a brand new
social media platform that encouraged
free speech
that's brilliant will it be able to show
off my sick abs on it as well
hopefully not the new platform is called
retalk and it is
absolutely exploding right now they have
discussion forums around any topic
from gardening to ancient history all
the way to current politics
that sounds great but a lot of these
free speech platforms
just attract all the worst people from
both sides
or as we call them here trigonometry
fans correct
joking aside what makes retalk different
is it's moderated to keep away
extremists but instead of being uber
work they take a balanced view to
moderation
wow how do they find so many moderators
who don't have pink hair i don't know
maybe they hire people from all over the
political spectrum
great joke mate no big tech company
would ever do that
retalk insists on civility and they're
particularly keen to foster
conversations for people in the center
and on the center right
you can even go on there and discuss
trigonometry and your favorite episodes
so all i need to do to access this great
site is click on the link and it will
take me straight there yep and if you're
a listener
go to retalk.com that's r e t
a l k dot com and start having
intelligent conversations you know
they'll be intelligent conversations
because francis hasn't worked out how to
join yet
i haven't if we racialize the discussion
of crime punishment
and policing in america we are
playing with fire
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitson
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a professor at brown
university
who became the first black tenured
professor at harvard at the age of 33.
glenn larry welcome to trigonometry oh
thank you consultant
it's great to have you on the show
listen uh our american fans will be very
well aware of who you are but for anyone
else where in the world who watches our
show who is not familiar with your
career and your story tell everybody who
are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey that leads you to here
sitting with us chatting about some of
the things we'll be talking about
i could go on about that for a long time
uh well first of all let me correct you
i was the first black tenured professor
of economics
at harvard university yes um i was
born in chicago uh in 1948 uh
grew up in a working-class family went
to public schools
uh became a father very young at the age
of 18
dropped out of college and went to work
eventually found my way back to the
university part-time at first and then
full-time
with a full-time job long story
but i graduated northwestern university
in 1972
with a degree in mathematics and studied
uh
economics at mit in the early 1970s
where i took my phd in 1976.
um i started my career as a technical
economist writing math papers
uh but evolved into a politically
oriented and social critic
type economist writing about race and
inequality
i was naturally drawn to those questions
um
i became a reagan conservative in the
1980s
uh became a born-again christian in the
late 1980s
uh dealt with a sex scandal and
a serious drug problem got those things
behind me
regrounded my career left harvard went
to boston university in the 90s and
i've been here at brown since 2005. um
i have of late become notorious as a
center-right critic of the black lives
matter movement about which i assume
we'll talk more and do course
but think of myself as a centrist uh not
as a particularly
partisan uh political actor um
so that's me yeah and it's great to have
you on the show because that's basically
where francis and i both are as well
we're just trying to make
our way in the world understand what
different people say on different sides
uh without taking any particular party
line at all
um but let let me ask you a question we
don't pretend to be experts on the show
which is why we
invite people like you on but the
question that a lot of ordinary people
around the world might be asking about
america now i think is
just over 12 years ago america
elected and inaugurated its first black
president
with overwhelming support to huge
enthusiasm of course there were people
who were against it
but the overwhelming support was
definitely there it was it was something
that reverberates around the world i
remember where i was when barack obama
was elected where he was when he was
inaugurated
even though i didn't particularly have
much of an interest in politics
at the time what has happened since
that america now finds itself in the
place that it finds itself now
well that's a very good question um
one way of responding is that we've been
seized by a mass hysteria
completely disconnected from reality
that has a life of its own driven by the
interest of particular
political actors maybe the democratic
party and seeking votes from black
people maybe
various kinds of activists who are able
to pursue their own political interests
on the back of this narrative about
uh systemic racism and white supremacy
that that would be one way
of responding i think there's some truth
to it
um these incidents uh the killing of
trayvon martin
in sanford florida in 2012 if i'm not
mistaken
the killing of michael brown in ferguson
missouri in
2013 or 14 again i may get the date not
quite right
um these incidents eric garner
selling cigarettes out in front of a
cafe a convenience store in
staten island new york city choked to
death by a police officer
and i could go on with these incidents i
have
catalyzed a movement black lives matter
for sure um which sees the imagination
of many
um and has four minutes this uh
this uh change in the uh conversation
about race uh here in the united states
uh then most recently of course george
floyd in
minneapolis minnesota uh choked to death
a famously
uh inflammatory and infuriating
uh incident uh has galvanized uh
uh people in this uh in this movement
uh this movement which spilled over into
street protest and demonstration
demonstrations which on occasion spilled
over into rioting and
arson and violence a lot of angry
rhetoric
uh coming out of it uh i'm not going to
pretend to
have the answer to your question what's
going on
but the race conversation in my opinion
has definitely become less productive
more
volatile um angrier
uh uh less capable of being resolved
from
the parties on various sides and
in my opinion i think to some degree
disconnected from the reality which the
election and successful
eight-year term of barack hussein obama
reflects this is not the same country
that we were in 1920 or 1950 or even
1980
the very fact that the anti-racist
advocacy
attracts as much support as it does from
mainstream political interests
from corporate america uh from the
common opinion of the editorial pages of
major organs and so on
that uh books like tadahasi cults is
between the world and me or
ibrahmax kindies how to be an
anti-racist
have as much cachet as they have
that the cultural awards coming from
places like the pulitzer prize
award foundation or the macarthur genius
awards foundation or
whatever it might be have celebrated
african-american
uh assertion of african-american
interests have
gotten behind the woke narrative about
race
those facts seem to may give the lie to
the claim
that the society is intrinsically racist
or
that people who advocate on behalf of
the interests of african-americans are
powerless
uh quite the opposite it seems to me is
the case
so i don't know i could ramble on but
you've asked me how in the face of
barack obama's ascendancy could
the tenor of the complaint about race in
america be such as it is
intrinsically white supremacist
anti-black and so on
my answer is mass hysteria has seized us
here
and common sense you know recitation of
actual facts on the ground
uh has been displaced by the emotional
uh fervor into which people can be uh
whipped
uh by self-interested advocates who have
their own agendas
and you say that they have their own
agendas glenn if i could push back just
a little bit surely though
these these arguments must have a kernel
of truth to them
otherwise they'd be easy to dismiss and
they wouldn't they they wouldn't rear
their head again
well yeah they have occurred i mean
george floyd is dead i mean everybody
saw the video
the guy said derek shoving the police
officer with his knee on the man's neck
for as long as he sat with his knee on
his neck that happened there's not any
doubt about that
uh moreover uh the relationship
between police and members of the
community in many cities across this
country members of the african-american
community in many cities across this
country are fraught
uh they're front because there are bad
acting police there's not any doubt
about that there are incidents that
happen
more than incidents happening there are
institutionalized forces
that uh impinge upon the quality of life
for african americans
uh in ways that are that are
objectionable
that's certainly a part of the story but
the idea that
um there's a kind of
systemic violent
terrorizing of african americans by
police officers is simply false
simply false because there are 40
million african americans here
in a country of 330 million people
there are about 1 200 police killings
of americans in a year of which maybe
about
300 are african americans of which maybe
about
50 or 60 i make the number up we could
check it are
unarmed african americans killed by
police officers a country of 330 million
people
there are tens of thousands of
encounters between police officers and
citizens
on a daily basis here there are hundreds
of thousands of arrests
of people for suspicion of criminal
offense
per year in this country so
these incidents which are real are not
emblematic of the experience of people
in the country they are not
representative
of what's happening on a daily basis
they're only a part
of the narrative i mean i feel obliged
to observe
that some 8 000 black people were
murdered
uh in the year 2020 that's 8 000
compared to maybe 300 who were killed by
police officers
and maybe 50 or 60 of those 300 who were
killed under circumstances where you
would not
immediately say the police officer was
justified in using force
so it's a question of what's the actual
experience of people
and then what's the narrative that gets
affixed to that experience
the actual experience is much more
benign i i will use that word much more
benign
than the narrative of police hunting
down black people at every turn
and that narrative narrative leaves out
the fact that the police are out there
encountering people who are committing
crimes
mostly against other black people this
is not an easy job this is a difficult
job now i'm making no brief
for racist police officers who exist i'm
just saying
if we put the circumstances into some
kind of realistic uh proportionality
of the narrative i think would be much
more different the narrative about
threats to
the integrity of the black body about
black lives mattering
would be very much different because the
actual
threat to the integrity of the black
black body the actual
extirpation of black life is being
carried out not by
police officers under cover of law but
rather
by common criminals who behave viciously
who have
to be dealt with i say that with
trepidation i don't take any pleasure
saying it but if you go and ask people
who live in these neighborhoods
they're going to tell you that they're
worried about having a carjacker put a
pistol
in their faces at one o'clock in the
morning when they're trying to fill
their tank
that they're worried about sending their
child out for a carton of milk at the
store on the corner because sometimes
the child
doesn't come back that they hear gunfire
at night before they put their children
to bed and they cower
in fear of what might what that might uh
entail
so the painting of the circumstances of
african americans
as susceptible to rogue
vicious violent intervention in their
lives by agents of the state
is false it's not true
and glenn where would you stand on the
fact that
the argument that american police
disproportionately target
uh black people in particular young
black men
and that's the reason why they're over
represented when it comes to the
prison system in america i wouldn't say
with the same degree of finality that
that is false because there is some
evidence
uh especially with the use of of force
short of lethal force that
uh race plays a role in that police
officers are more aggressive
more likely to put on hands more likely
to use handcuffs more likely to use a
baton
more likely to rough up a suspect if the
suspect is black
um and there are uh police departments
in which the culture of
cowboy uh vigilante kind of violence you
know we're the good guys there the black
guys we got to go out and get our quota
today
uh is uh operative uh
so there is there is uh an issue in
policing of course there are there's
another side to that story there are
many police departments in which
innovative community relations
initiatives have been undertaken people
working cooperatively with police and so
on to try to solve
the problem of securing public safety uh
for people i i wouldn't pooh-pooh uh the
issue of policing
i i would say reform uh is
an appropriate item on the agenda it's
just the
the the relative weighting of the
various different threats now the other
thing that i would say here is
there's an unavoidable problem
here which is that if you have high
rates of offending
uh in a racially identifiable community
it's going to be very hard for law
enforcement to ignore
that fact so even if the proportion of
offenders
is a small proportion of the total
population which is certainly true
the fraction of young black men in any
city who have a gun
tucked in their belt who are prepared to
pull it out and use it on a police
officer it's got to be a low number
i mean i don't know the number but it's
got to be a small small percentage
still if it's a
large percentage who are black of those
who are prepared to behave in this way
a police officer at two o'clock in the
morning pulling someone over because
they're driving erratically
noticing that it's a young black man in
the front seat of the vehicle
it's hard to ask that person not to be
mindful of the fact that there's a risk
involved in that situation
not to have his sense of that risk
heightened by observing that the person
is black
now this is an officer of the state this
is someone who is a servant of the
people
this is someone who has been through
many many many hours of training
they should be so instructed that
their responsibilities require them
to suppress whatever their visceral
reactions might be and to conduct their
encounter with a citizen regardless of
race
courteously respectfully etc etc
but they're also human beings it's it's
if
as private citizens we're coming home
from a party
after a few drinks at one o'clock in the
morning on a dark street
and we observe two or three people
walking toward us on the other side of
the street
you can't tell me that our reaction in
that situation is not going to be
conditioned by whether or not those are
old ladies
uh or young men whether or not they are
black or they are white
uh whether or not they are dressed with
uh business suits on carrying an attache
case
or they have a hoodie on uh and they
have their hands in their pocket
we are as social animals conditioned to
take that kind of information on board
so are police officers
uh going to be socially conditioned
their training should work to counteract
that
but to expect that they would be
completely oblivious to that
i think is a request that's going to be
very difficult to enforce
well we're having the conversation that
we've had with coleman hughes and with
others
uh very much going through similar
themes what i wonder though if
maybe we can take it in a new direction
would be
what does a healthy conversation about
this issue look like
because uh you know at the moment it's
all very much one side
says everything is white supremacy
everything is systemic
everything needs to be defunded
overthrown and the other side
is saying well actually this is because
this group of people commits more crime
and actually police officers are just
doing a good job and yet
people are some a small number of people
are being killed as you said yourself
there is some evidence that
black suspects are treated differently
to white suspects uh et cetera so
how do we talk about this issue in a
healthy way
as opposed to having this uh tension and
culture war over it
well you're gonna say i'm a pollyanna
for saying this i think we need to
de-racialize
the conversation that we need to talk
about policing about citizens
about the rights of people about about
the
responsibilities of public agents as
they interact with their
uh with their charges not about blacks
and whites
and asians and so on that's what i think
we need i think all lives matter
i think that should be the mantra all
lives matter now
in saying that then i laugh because it
has we have gotten to the point where if
i say
all lives matter it's almost as if i'm
saying blue lives matter if you get what
i mean
if i say all lies matter it's almost as
if i've taken a side against
black interest by saying that all lies
matter i have not done so i think
um i was at a conference once and i
tried to make this
uh move that i'm making with you right
now and i got my head handed to me by
the audience who called me uncle tom
and said that i had my head in the stand
and i was ignoring reality but here's my
argument
my argument is yeah there is a
disproportion in the way in which police
use force against citizen based upon
race and that needs to be
dealt with yes there is and yes there
are these incidents like george floyd
and
so on that happen which cannot be
ignored
and the people responsible for them
should be held accountable
i grant that i grant all of that
but if we racialize the discussion of
crime
punishment and policing in america
we are playing with fire
on the one hand there is the claim that
advocates of black interests will make
police are racist black lives matter we
must focus on their
excesses on the other hand there is the
unspoken conversation that goes on
sub rosa that goes on beneath the access
to the tv camera in the microphone
which is that there's a tremendous
amount of black crime
in this country and i'm sick of it okay
that that's another kind of conversation
uh ferguson missouri just outside of st
louis
has a horrific not just ferguson but the
entire st louis metropolitan area has a
horrific
profile in terms of criminal
victimization in terms of homicide
in terms of assault in terms of robbery
and burglary
and car theft and uh so on um
those people living in that community
i'm talking about the white people
are aware that most of the offenders are
black
that's the last thing that we want to
reiterate in their consciousness the
offenders are americans who are breaking
the law and who have to be dealt with
that they are disproportionately black
is something that should not be brought
to the forefront of the consciousness of
people
it's something that we should attempt to
tamp down we shouldn't feed the reflex
to see it in that way
the progressive advocates of black
interest
make an error when they think that they
can play only one side
of this card and get away with they can
play it on
msnbc or cnn or the cbs news of the new
york times on one side because
those organs will never give voice to a
commonly held sentiment
which is that in many many cities in
america it's way too dangerous to step
outside of your home
and the unspoken subtext there is
the reason is way too dangerous is
because there are too many black
criminals roaming the streets of these
cities
that's what people may be inclined more
frequently to think
if we frame the police violent problem
in racial terms way more white people
than black people are killed by police
in america
every year for every incidence of a
tamir rice that's the young boy 12 years
old
shot when he had a toy gun in a park in
cleveland
who has become acosta left brightly
because he should not have lost his life
under those circumstances
that was terrible policing he happened
to have been a black kid they're white
kids
who have been killed that way i can't
remember the name of the gentleman an
african-american in a walmart who had a
a gun that he was trying to buy and got
killed by store security officers
because they thought that he was a
threat but there have been white people
killed under those circumstances there
have been white people choked to death
by police officers kneeling on their
necks after
they've had difficulty arresting the
suspect
these problems need not be primarily
seen through a racial lens
in my view progress
would consist in moving the conversation
from one about
generic claims of racial domination to
one about the responsibilities of public
officers in their interactions with
citizens of all races
and one of the reasons that i think that
is because there's a lot of black crime
a lot of it if you if you're inclined to
think of the crime in racial terms
if you want to racialize the
conversation about law enforcement
policing
punishment and prisons in this country
there is a dark
subtext there that we would do well to
be mindful of and not to encourage that
to come into life
you're going to call those racists
excuse me constitution they're going to
girlfriend
they think they're winning the argument
because they can call the people who are
afraid of black crime and are prepared
to say so
racist they're not winning that argument
those people don't care that you're
calling them racist they know that it's
not
racist to be afraid of carjackers
and if most of them are black it's not
racist to be afraid of the black guy who
pulls up next to you at one o'clock in
the morning at the
at the gas station where you're trying
to fill your car if you smell marijuana
coming out of the front window
you've got to be and you see that's a
black uh 19 year old
you're not crazy to think that that
person might harm you
um and and that's not the kind of thing
that we want to feed into this is what
i'm saying forgive me for interrupting
your constitution
i mean these conversations are very very
difficult to have
on both sides and i take your point
about
we need to stop racializing this
conversation
but isn't that impossible glenn in a
world where we racialize
literally everything now everything now
has become racialized to a degree
well i grew up in a multicultural part
of south london
amongst black people white people asian
people latino people whatever
and i went to school and it wasn't as
much as an issue it feels like as it is
now
it feels we've gone backwards yeah i
agree with that and i don't know quite
what to say about it
your point is well taken i could be just
spitting in the wind
i i could be just tilting at a windmill
here
uh arguing for a move away from the
racialization of a discourse which has
become progressively
more focused on race you know i don't
know how to turn the clock back
i only know to say what it is that i
think is right and hope that people will
listen
but that's not a strategy and and i
frankly do not have
a strategy that i think could actually
work
here in terms of i mean there's some
people who are talking about
we have to change the language and
whatnot there are you know
uh the the there are rumblings of a kind
of counter movement
uh in in the fringes uh but but i don't
see it i mean
the the um
the center of the discourse has
definitely shifted uh in a direction
that i don't think is entirely healthy
so
um i'm sorry i i can't give you an
affirmative response
that says oh no no don't worry things
are gonna get better i'm rather
pessimistic but i think i know how we
should be reacting here
and that's what i'm trying to give voice
to well yeah and i hear you i think
you know you talk about the impact of
racializing everything and it's becoming
quite obvious i think now to anyone who
is an independent observer that
if you racialize these different
conversations you inevitably
end up creating racism against groups
which for one reason or another do
better in certain circumstances
suddenly people are again you know as a
jew for example people are going
oh why are the jews so successful why
are the asian americans so successful
why do chinese kids do better at school
in our country in the uk here
why is it that white working class boys
don't do so well in education and
suddenly
everything is about race and suddenly
you're going why is that group doing
better than that
group and inevitably everybody finds
themselves in a position where
they are either the oppressor or they're
oppressed one way or another and we
we're just stuck
in this crazy way and i think maybe
maybe that awareness that suddenly ev
every group is being looked at as a
potential victim or a potential
victimizer
might make some people wake up to this
do you think that that's a possibility
i don't know um here's what i think um i
think there's a contradiction
at the heart of the identitarian
argument for group equality the
identitarian argument for group equality
is we have these different groups we
have jews we have south asians we have
east asians we have blacks we have
latinos
whatever um and they have identities
and they the identities deserve to be
respected someone tells me
i identify as an african-american and
that's a part of their
personhood and it wants to be respected
taken on board
given credence so groups matter
in the identitarian view of the world
it's not a matter of indifference it's
not like we're all a part of the human
family
we are in these various little boxes
groups matter
group ness matters my black culture and
heritage matters to me
the music that i listen to the food that
i eat the literature that i read
the stories i tell my children that's
important
groups matter there's groupness on the
other hand we think they're supposed to
be equality of groups across
every human enterprise but how can that
be because if groups matter some people
are going to bounce a basketball
a hundred thousand times a month and
other people are gonna bounce it ten
thousand times a month
some people are going to uh be drawn to
the book
as a way of experiencing human culture
and other people are going to be more
verbal or more
spontaneous or whatever it might be
there are differences between groups
groups matters after all they're not all
the same they don't read the same things
they don't believe the same things
they don't do the same things with their
time so now i've got population groups
that matter
groups are different groups have their
own integrity
they express it in the way in which they
live their lives that's going to result
in a different representation of group
members across various human activities
they're not all going to be in the
academy to the same extent
they're not all going to be in sports to
the same extent they're
they're not all going to do the same
occupations they're not all going to
have the same professional profile
now i look out at society and i see a
difference between groups and the
proportion who are
i don't know members of the national
academy of sciences
uh tenured faculty members at harvard
university
uh tech entrepreneurs in silicon valley
hedge fund managers uh traders on the
floor of the stock exchange
etc i see differences in the proportion
who are getting phds in american
or british english literature who etc
groups mattered after all the groupness
the jewishness
the blackness reflected itself to some
degree and how people spent their time
and therefore and what it is that
they're doing and yet i
insist that the society is unfair unless
i get an equal proportionate
representation of these groups in every
human
enterprise that's a contradiction and
it's a contradiction that's only going
to lead to
tyranny and racism you would make a
progressive
or progressive minded person so
incredibly uncomfortable by what you're
saying right now because what i think at
the heart
of what you're saying is equality
between groups
is never going to be possible that is
what i'm saying if we think groups
matter and we respect the differences
between them
now we can blend it all together we can
say you can't teach your kid like that
you can't send them to the private
school over here
you can't spend more time on this
everybody has to be the same
we can flatten all of the cultural and
behavioral
distinctions that are the actual
substance of groupness
and put everybody into one social
media and then uh imagine that we're
going to have equality but that would be
tyrannical
that would be overriding people's
autonomy as individual human beings to
associate with
each other and to believe what they
please we're going to end up with the
question
how come there are so many jews who are
getting phds in electrical engineering
how come there's so many asians who are
uh doing this or doing that that's the
that's ultimately where the question
leads the qu the presumption
of group equality in the face of
group distinctions of social
organization and culture
leads either to the current tyrannical
imposition of standards which attempt to
tamp down
the authentic expression of groupness or
to a finger-pointing suspicion every
time we see somebody pop their head up
above the level zone is the wondering if
if the blacks are underrepresented and
the jews are overrepresented well why is
that there must be some
intrinsic unfairness that's built into
the system
uh and that is a problem
kkk do you like feeling silky and smooth
like a sexual dolphin never talk to me
again
what if i told you that manscaped have
brought out a new
and improved lawnmower 3.0 that allows
you to be fresh
and trim for the ladies down below
i've been married 20 years the last time
i was fresh and trimmed down below
jimmy savile was a respected children's
entertainer i'm going to ignore that
the lawnmower has a cutting cutting-edge
ceramic blade which reduces the risk of
having an accident
where you least want an accident my bank
account no you idiot you know
los were bus oh right plus it's
waterproof
which means you can groom in the shower
and it has an
led light so you can get a really
accurate
and precise trim x to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is of course
trigger that's 20 off with free shipping
at manscape.com and use our code trigger
your werewolfs well thank you excellent
and isn't also part of the problem here
that uh so i'm going to talk about it
from a british perspective so
i'm i'm a former teacher everybody who
watches a show will
have a drink now but you know people
would say oh you know
you know the black kids aren't doing
well and i'm like well that's
actually not true west african girls in
the uk education system
are one of the highest achieving
subgroups in the whole of education
you know and then and and then when you
i t i used to teach in london people go
oh this you know this is a black school
well there's a fundamental difference
between
caribbean kids or british caribbean
british african first generation african
different attitudes different cultures
so just to refer to
one group of people is black or another
group as latino when someone can be
venezuelan and honduran
it's it's completely reductive different
cultures
agree no
it's a good point that francis makes i
want to talk about economics a little
bit because that
you know that's your forte uh and i
think
that's a big part of this conversation
do you think that a lot of these
problems in talking about these issues
honestly come from the fact that
we've essentially abandoned what used to
be called the class
analysis the idea that people really
struggle in life
first and foremost because they grow up
in poverty in areas where there's
substandard housing there's a lot of
crime
uh there's not the education is not good
uh they're not surrounded by uh
inspiring examples of attainment and
success
and that is something that is much more
universal
across all these different racial groups
who are struggling in certain areas
than their skin color or whatever else
it might be
the thing that really holds people down
is being
being poor growing up in poverty etc do
you think that's
the abandonment of that viewpoint is why
everything has now become so racialized
yes i i agree with that uh i am not a
leftist
but i think that i was trained in the
conventional
um sort of uh neo-liberal
economic school at mit back in the 1970s
and have
as i have already confessed uh you know
flirted with the right wing of american
politics in terms of uh
economic policy and so on i'm not a
marxist i'm not a socialist
uh on the other hand i think there is
a profound truth in the argument i
associated with adolf reid the political
scientists
at the university of pennsylvania here
in the united states but there are many
many others
who are very concerned about race and
racial inequality
there's not any doubt that they're
concerned about the interests of african
americans
but who understand the problem mainly
through a class lens it's the
disproportionate representation of
blacks
at the bottom of the class hierarchy
that's the
problem now i'm not about to nationalize
industries and declare 20
an hour minimum wages and all of that
that's not how i would approach it as a
policy matter
but having as the goal improving the
quality of life for people at the bottom
expanding their access to developmental
resources giving them greater
opportunities
for themselves and their children
ensuring that they have adequate health
care that they have added
access to good education that their
housing
is decent and so on their food security
uh concerns are ameliorated
this this kind of thing that should be
the goal
now i i say that both for the reasons
that i've already intimated which is i
think we over do the racialization
but i also say it from a kind of
pragmatic political
perspective you want to get something
done in a democracy you need 50 percent
of the people to get behind it if you're
a racial minority group
by definition you're not 50 of the
people if you claim
frame your politics entirely in terms of
your racial identity
you might be able to cobble together a
coalition of the lgbt
and of the brown and of the black and
the so on
but you'd be much more effective if you
drew on
some of that 60 or 70 percent of the
population who were white
uh the working class of that segment of
the population on behalf of a program of
politics
that tries to expand opportunity for
people at the bottom of the society
if you did that you have a greatest
chance of being successful politically
and you target your intervention in a
way that it was most likely to help
those in the minority group who are the
ones most
in need but those people the poor people
in the minority group the poor black
people
in the urban ghettos of america don't
give news conferences they don't write
speeches for politicians
they don't write op-ed pieces they are
not on the faculty of the universities
the people who speak for the minority
group are largely themselves not members
of the class
within the minority group who most
desperately need
attention they're interested in whether
or not they're going to get a job at the
university
and whether or not the cabinet of joseph
biden is ethnically or racially diverse
and whether or not the fortune 500
company that they work for hires a
consultant to come in and do diversity
training and whether or not the
university has affirmative action
they have a class interest it's a
middle and upper middle class
professional interest
they racialize their um
offensive ethically offensive class
interest they're already privileged
people
they now just want a better job in a
higher income and more attention to
their concerns
they racialize that under cover of
acting on behalf of the poor
when in fact the most effective way of
acting on behalf of the poor would be to
de-emphasize race and emphasize their
class differentiation that would be my
analysis you know it's a very accurate
analysis i would say because
you do see you know people quote and you
know always talk about aoc you know
she's a latino woman
you know she's puerto rican she's on the
left that's what latinos are
and you know like my mom is venezuelan
again everybody drinks she's pro-trump
you know she's on the right as are a lot
of cubans you know because they've
experienced
you know socialism etc etc yet these are
not deemed to be the correct
views for a latin american to hold
and i wonder why a latin american person
would be pro-trump
um what what what and i'll bet you
to some degree they thought perhaps
incorrectly but nevertheless they
thought
trump was giving voice to some of their
class-based concerns
uh you know there was something else you
alluded to which
uh i'm not a conspiratorially minded
person at all uh glenn
a posture that has been rather
challenged by the events of the last
year
i must say uh but but i do
wonder whether making everything about
race is a really great way of avoiding
actually having to do anything for
ordinary people and their concerns
it seems like a great way to get people
to fight amongst themselves
while elites continue to to benefit and
prosper do you think there's some truth
to that as well
yeah if if my wife lawn were here my
lovely wife
she and i argued this point all the time
she was a bernie sanders supporter in
the last election cycle here in the
united states
she'd be saying right on right on yes i
do
when joseph biden basically secured the
democratic nomination in the south
carolina primary
with the help of james clyburn the
member of congress from south carolina
the democratic party in south carolina
south carolina conservative state but
the democratic party a very black and
relatively liberal
uh congregation uh saved joseph biden
from an ignominious
humiliation by coming out and having him
win that primary and he then went on to
to the nomination i mean her concern was
precisely this it was
you know they're just trying to avoid
the issue here they're just there it's a
corporate democrat who's going to come
in and say that
something that's not all that much
different from what a corporate
republican was going to say
meanwhile the gut level issues about the
working people about money in american
politics about
about how the fat cats always get
protected about wall street uh
end up getting ignored you know they're
they're feeding them uh
you know a pebble they're they're
they're just uh playing with them
they're exploiting them
by uh appealing to their racial uh
sensibility rather than
uh going for the jugular in american
politics which would be going after the
guys with the money
that's that's my wife that's not me but
i do have to listen to it every day and
some of you
some of it she sounds like a great lady
glenn
so you don't agree i take it then what
is your
refutation of that analysis now that
you're safe from your wife's
punishment for actually expressing it
well you know i mean i i think markets
and capitalism are actually the way to
go i mean
i think you don't you don't want to shut
stuff down you want to open stuff up
you do want to have a robust safety net
so you want to take care of people who
are displaced let's say by trade or
whatever
uh i don't like the minimum wage i would
subsidize people's wages the reason i
don't like the minimum wage as an
economist is that i think it's a very
inefficient way of helping people
who are poor i think it basically prices
out of the labor market individuals who
have
a few skills and i i worry that it
encourages employers toward
automation tendencies that you know they
try to minimize their dependence on
labor that's becoming more expensive
that will have
a long-term detrimental effect for the
well-being of
poor people if you want them to have
money give them money don't
uh force the employer to pay him more
than the employer thinks that's the kind
of thing that i would be inclined to say
sure so so the you know the differences
are more about
how to get something done than they are
about what needs doing
uh glenn and what would you say to the
idea that your position is great and
it's very very utopian
but the problem is not capitalism it's
crony capitalism the system is rigged
there's lots of evidence to to to say
that and really these people at the
bottom have
little to no chance of making their way
up
i'd say i understand why you're saying
that i i think there's some
more than a little bit of truth to it i
think there's welfare
you know uh money for poor people money
for people who can't pay their rent who
can't uh buy the food that their kids
need and so forth
and then there's uh corporate welfare
which is a
an act of congress that protects an
industry
from competitive pressures uh and ends
up putting billions of dollars
or there's uh hedge fund uh capitalism
where
uh the rules of the financial
marketplace are
configured in such a way as to protect
people or there's
tax cuts for the rich quote unquote tax
cuts for the rich
i don't think all of the tax cut
initiatives undertaken
under trump were bad i talk about it at
my podcast with my economist friend
larry kotlikoff was a tax expert
there were some things that needed doing
in the tax code that got done in that
legislation
which promote efficient allocation of
resources etc etc
but there was also a lot of uh you know
fat cats getting paid
rules getting configured so as to make
it easier to make money and keep the
money that you make
uh if you're a well-off person so crony
capitalism is a real thing
uh it is a threat to the
political integrity as well as the
economic
efficiency of the american political
economy every bit as much or more
than the welfare state kind of uh
handouts to poor people and so on it
deserves
a much greater degree of attention and
both parties are guilty
uh to it i mean i i would just tell you
i didn't vote for
uh bernie sanders while he wasn't on the
ballot
um and i probably wouldn't have voted
for him if he had been on the ballot i
could say i'm not a socialist i'm i'm a
little bit worried
about that but but
uh of everybody who was speaking during
the 2020 election cycle
he's the one who actually made me sit up
on the edge of my chair and pay
attention to what he was saying he was
actually
talking about the things that need to be
talked about
um it's an interesting point bret our
friend brett weinstein when we had him
on the show i mean this is i'm sure
you'll be aware something he talks about
the fact that the two-party system
is designed to reflect the interest of
the people who are in those parties
at the very top not not of people and
what you do about that is obviously a
very difficult question but
uh you alluded to you or you referred
rather to joseph biden a few times i
wanted to
get your take on the early days of the
biden administration
uh some of the executive orders we've
seen uh
certainly you know the conversation we
were having a few minutes ago about
race and not making everything about
race i'm not sure
it's seen quite in the same way in the
biden white house what do you make of
him
so far and of what his administration is
likely to do in your opinion
i'm concerned i mean it's early yet and
i
i want to give the benefit of the doubt
and things are going to shake out and
and we'll see
i think there's a demonstration effect
you know the first 100 days i want to do
a certain set of things
i'm going to sign this executive order
on day one
he did get elected with a constituency
uh
and those who speak on behalf of that
constituency
and i'm talking about racial minorities
as an important part of that
constituency
have at the top of their list certain
things so trump has a
kind of anti-critical race theory
initiative that he says the government
employment services will not rely on
training
uh public employees according to the
doctrines of the what he regards trump
as a more
radical critical race theory biden comes
in the first thing he does one of the
first things he does
is to rescind that um he wants to make
it clear that he's moving in a different
direction
on the race related issues than was
donald trump after all
joseph robinette biden has informed the
american people that the reason that he
ran
for president when he that the thing
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back that
decided it for him was the support that
trump purportedly gave to white
supremacists
at the charlottesville after the
charlottesville incident
of course trump didn't support white
supremacists his words were
quite explicit and not supporting but
never mind never mind
biden has to some degree defined himself
as vice president kamala harris an
african-american
woman etc um and so he has to come out
of the box demonstrating his commitment
and
signaling that he's on a very different
uh side of the question than was the
previous administration
so therefore some of these things i'm
not all that happy
about his uh uh posturing uh
on uh on behalf of critical race theory
um
i would have you know and you can infer
from what i've already said here
uh many doubts about that um i
i'm happy that an african-american has
ascended to the position of secretary of
defense assuming he's confirmed by the
united states senate that's a good thing
i suppose i mean i'm not against it i
you know it's a symbolically significant
thing and so forth and so on
but you know it hardly scratches the
surface of what actually needs to be
done it is
symbolic after all uh not really
substantive move in the direction of
justice and equality for african
americans but i'm not
i'm not i'm not going to be a curmudgeon
pooh-poohing
something that seems to be on the whole
uh
a uh reasonable thing to do um so i'm
keeping my powder dry
i'm not gonna jump around and start
castigating biden
uh for doing things that uh out of
political
necessity probably have to be done let
me see what the larger picture comes to
look like after a few months and
um i'll have a have more to say about
that
and do you think the from what you've
seen that the biden administration is
actually going to target
the some of the issues that we've talked
about you know
the fact that the lower classes in
america are struggling financially
there's going to be more support for
them or do you think there's going to be
more focus on the critical race theory
and amping up the culture war i don't
know
i certainly hope the former and not the
latter um
i i think some of this culture war stuff
as i say is just built into the cake
because
you had um you know
the electoral outcome uh the left
quote-unquote have won
they've been in the wilderness uh
they've had to endure donald trump
uh they want to see some changes how
deeply that runs
i don't know i want to know who's going
to be in the justice department in
charge of the civil rights division
i i want to know who's going to be at
the education department
uh in terms of what they do about uh
equity and inclusion
stuff i want to hear some of the
speeches that are going to be given uh
by the new president uh as he tries to
point the nation
forward and see what he places his
emphasis on uh if i feel that those
speeches are being written by the usual
suspects of of uh racial uh
uh chauvinism and and uh race-based
advocacy
i'll object uh on the other hand there's
an opportunity here
uh for the president to not simply
react uh but to foster a
coherent positive vision for what it is
that we should be doing
i would hope that that vision would take
cognizance of the fact
that trump actually did get 70 plus
million
votes that there are a lot of
working-class people who were attracted
to his anti-establishmentarianism
that many many americans of all colors
feel that the two parties have not uh
fostered their interests and that that
is not mainly a racial issue
there's reason to hope that that kind of
wisdom
uh would be reflected in the new
administration and certainly
i would advocate that yeah well one of
the things that i think a lot of people
are
massively sleeping on is if it hadn't
been for covert 19 it's almost certain
that donald trump would have been
re-elected
and so the idea that trumpism has been
defeated i think his
way of over optimistic what seems to me
to have happened is
covert came along it discredited him
quite a bit
obviously he was an off-putting
character to a lot of moderate people as
well
put those two things together but it
doesn't change the reality i mean
every way you look now whether it's this
gamestop thing
ordinary people are not happy with the
elites and they're trying to do
something about it and they're
increasingly aware
that they have people power through
technology and that that is a battle
i've been saying is going to play out
over
over the next period of time uh
hopefully your optimism about the biden
administration is
is right but you mentioned critical race
theory maybe that's something we can
wrap up the interview with can you just
explain to ordinary people who keep
hearing this
this these terms critical race theory
what are they talking about what what is
it simply put
i think what they're saying this goes
back a long way this goes back to
the 1980s uh the literature in the legal
academy about race and and inequality
and
um i i think they're arguing that
uh one view of racial discrimination
is this kind of one-off unfair treatment
of individual persons based upon race
but there is a deeper structural
foundation
for racial inequality and it has to do
with things that are not so much the
treatment of individuals but the way in
which we
organize economic activity the way in
which physical space in the cities is
organized the way in which the laws are
promulgated
so i give an example to be concrete mass
incarceration mass incarceration
on the critical race theoretic
sensibility
is not just that the police are
put catching people uh based upon their
race and
more likely to a cost or to detain
an african-american because they're
racially discriminatory it's that the
constituencies that enact the laws which
are being enforced by the police
are indifferent to the consequences of
those enactments
for communities of color because there's
a devaluation
of the worth or the personhood of the
people who are communities of
who are in the communities of color the
the systemic
reach of racial unfairness it insinuates
itself into
every nook and cranny of the society's
operation
so the commercial advertising program of
a sneaker company
would be fair game in terms of thinking
about racial oppression
um so the way in which uh educational
services are organized and delivered in
the cities would be fair game
now i may not be doing justice to this
because i am not a critical race theory
devil tay they would say things like uh
intersectionality
they they would say well you've got a
variety of different groups and we have
to think about how the
uh hegemonic uh domination of the white
male
cis normative hetero uh uh
people who are running the system uh
oppresses the native
population in this way oppresses women
in that way oppresses gays in this way
expresses trans in that way
oppresses immigrants in this way
oppresses black people
in that way um and therefore we have to
see all of these various
tentacles of oppression through a
centralized lens in which we um
uh understand how they interact and
support one another
again forgive me if i don't make a lot
of sense here because this is not my
story
but it's how i understand their story
moving from the rights of individual
persons not to be infringed upon because
of their
race or their sexuality to an
understanding of structures within a
system of economy and
polity and administrative law and
practice
and and and commercial activity and all
the rest
that work together so as to effect uh
a suppression of the interest and of of
the well-being of
of uh communities of color something
like that
i don't know did that make any sense did
that make it easy
it makes complete sense glenn um what
what's wrong with that
what's what's wrong with it what's wrong
about you know thinking that we need
equal representation what what's what's
the problem with this
well uh okay
uh you you catch me a little bit off
guard here but i'll try
okay um it essentializes and
reifies dimensions of our
uh humanity uh
to uh an excessive extent and
and it doesn't it's illiberal it it it's
uh
it is uh not taking the individual
person
seriously uh at some level uh and and
it's also
not accurate as a social scientific so
there's a normative argument which i
just made
it's the individual that should be the
focus of any theory of justice that we
elaborate not groups it's the individual
uh but there's also a question of if we
see disparities or
we see social problems to what extent
are they actually the result of the
forces
invoked by the critical race theory to
what extent does identity really
determine destiny
in the society and so on and i think
we talked about the police violence
question specifically and i've given my
view
but i think if you talked about
educational attainment if you talked
about the achievement of
of economic security if you talked about
wealth disparities
uh and so on if you talked about
underrepresentation of certain lines of
business enterprise and all of that
that the systemic racism white hegemonic
domination
critical race theoretic framework
doesn't actually
give an account of the of the data i
mean you
gave reference just a moment ago to
differences amongst various
uh african descended immigrant
populations in the uk
in terms of what's actually happening
their race is not
what's distinguishing between caribbean
uh origin and west african origin
uk second generation immigrant
populations is not their race
that's the issue it's their culture i'm
inclined to think
that's not within the orbit of the
critical race theoretic
reflections and there's a lot of stuff
that's like that
glenn we've got to wrap up in a moment
but there's one question that's just
occurred to me that i want to ask you
about if we
if we take the economic analysis that a
lot of the problems in
inner cities in black neighborhoods in
america
uh are the product of the economic
circumstance in which those people find
themselves
uh would it not be then reasonable to
argue that that is
the product of uh the various uh
discriminatory laws that were in place
in the united states
the the genuine uh widespread racism
that existed
in the united states uh in in the
previous century
uh particularly and obviously the the
the consequences of slavery now if if i
posit to you that that is a reasonable
argument to make
is it not then quite logical to suggest
that some form of reparations be made to
address that and to help those
communities
up so that they can operate on a level
playing field with everybody else
it's not illogical uh it's just mistaken
in my view let me explain why i think
it's mistaken
i think it's a it's a political misstep
i i i think it's the wrong way to frame
the problem
i'm responding to you now by
acknowledging by stipulating
that history casts a long shadow and
that the history of racial
oppression and exclusion in america is
partly implicated
in the disparities that we see today i
don't dispute that
and therefore it is natural and logical
to think that the right way to respond
to that history
is to monetize it in some sense and to
make transfers to people based
upon how they might be imagined to have
been affected by that history here's why
i think that that's a mistake
i don't think that there's a sum of
money large enough
to indemnify disadvantaged person a
person who didn't complete high
school who has very little skills who
has drug addiction problems
who has three or four kids and no
husband who is
basically on the outs of society i don't
think there's a
cash payment big enough to indemnify
them from the consequences in their
lives and their children's lives
of what history has uh bequeathed to
them
they've been dealt a very bad hand by
history
i worry that um reparations uh advocacy
should it succeed should it succeed in
bringing about fifty thousand dollars
per head of
cash transfers to african americans i
know that there are many arguments about
how reparations might be implemented
i just say that for the sake of
concreteness that it would guarantee
that five years 10 years 30 years 50
years from now
there would not still be jails
overflowing with young black men
there would not still be 70 of children
born to a black woman in this country
born to a woman without a husband
there might still be uh 16 year olds
reading at the
blacks reading on average at the same
level of proficiency as 12 year old
whites
that's the case today
i don't know that reparations would
cause that situation to be different in
10
20 or 50 years from now however what it
would do
is commodify the claim that african
americans have on the general public
for a attention to the problems that
beset our communities
it would commodify it and it would enact
a transaction
in which we will have been paid in
compensation for
the for what history has wrought that is
i think not a good situation to be
in to discharge the obligation i would
credit that there is a communal
obligation to be especially attentive
to the disadvantage suffered by african
americans i would advocate for
programs of intervention aimed at
reducing
uh the most deleterious effects
of that sort but i would object to
sitting across a bargaining table with
the rest of america
we have our moral capital on one side
they have their money on the other side
we push our moral capital into the
middle of the table they push these
chips over to us on the other side
and then we're done the the ability to
command the society's attention to the
ongoing
certain to be ongoing social maladies
afflicting
black america will have been
significantly diminished
better far better in my opinion
more moral and also more politically
effective
is to take our moral capital combine it
with the influence of others on behalf
of the creation of a decent social
contract for all americans
and get that implemented if that's
implemented
bad schools and black neighborhoods will
get attention
jails overflowing with black people will
come to be a big
social issue the needs of families etc
employment issues etc will be attended
to they'll be attended to for all
americans and therefore they will be
attended to for black americans
don't try to cut a separate deal with
america is my message to black people
that is a mistake
well said a very very powerful note to
end the conversation on glenn thank you
so much for coming on the show
the last question we always ask is
always the same one which is what is a
one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be
intermarriage you want to talk about
race
know that race is not something that
falls from the sky
race is the consequence of what we do in
other words the reason that we have all
these different groups
is because we reproduce those
differences through our social behavior
over time breaking down the barriers
between
racial groups means breaking down the
barriers between
intimacy amongst individual persons
the real solution here is a solution in
which
we don't allow our futures to be
dictated by our past
we don't understand ourselves i mean
after all to call myself black
i have to willfully trim huge branches
off of my family tree
because i have got ancestors who are
european you can tell that just by
looking at me
i am black but i am many things besides
that blackness today in america does not
have to be what blackness is in 50 years
or what blackness is in 100 years
uh it will sound like i'm advocating
intermarriage and maybe i
am to some degree but at least what i'm
advocating is talking about it
it's a very good point uh glenn thank
you so much
i mentioned of course at the beginning
that you're a professor uh but you also
put a lot of stuff
on youtube you have a podcast you you
write stuff
tell everybody where they can connect
more with the things that you're putting
out there
well my newsletter is at
glennlowery.substance.com
uh and my podcast the glenn show can be
supported and can be seen at patreon.com
forward slash glenn show
two wins one word so that's my podcast
said uh
and that's my sub stack newsletter and
i'm out there trying to
you know uh hold up the flag uh
in the spirit that you've heard me uh
exemplify here uh today so thanks for
having me on
constantin and francis thank you very
much thank you
we really appreciate you taking the time
to speak to us our fans will as well
uh and we thank them for watching and
we'll see you very soon with another
episode like this one or a live stream
all of them going out at 7 pm
take care and see you soon guys we hope
you've enjoyed this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below